we have to remember that
gerbil's office was not the office of
propaganda it was the office of
enlightenment of popular enlightenment
and propaganda so enlightenment
enlightenment was part of his
just the new era of enlightenment from
his perspective it was supposed to be
the new age a new era of enlightenment
it's a little bit like the the kind of
myth of hitler's failed artist and you
know his art is not that bad
you know there are a lot of artists who
are
who are worse and
i had a very interesting conversation
once with my my college roommate who
became a librarian at harvard
and at harvard he met an old old
librarian a german woman who had met
hitler as a kid
when she was like eight years old
her dad was like a gal lighter for the
nuremberg area
and she said that for 15 minutes hitler
goes out onto the
balcony with her
and has this conversation alone with
this you know eight-year-old girl
and she said he was charming and funny
and then he said he loved kids and she
she said he was the most you know
charming sort of person and
that's part of the history too that we
tend to forget when we make a scarecrow
image of this rabid
raging fanatic
you know that's there's more to it than
that
that's really really really important to
think about
when we make a scarecrow because
that gives you actionable
like it it forces you to introspect
about people in your own life or leaders
in your life today
ones you admire they're charismatic
they're friendly they love kids they
they talk about enlightenment
you have to kind of think all right am i
being duped on certain things
you have to kind of have a i mean that's
the problem with jeffrey epstein that
people don't seem to talk about i don't
i i never met the guy but
just given the people he talked to whom
i know
it feels like he must have been
charismatic yeah like people think about
like oh it's because of the women it's
because of the money
uh
i don't
the people i know i don't think they're
going to be influenced
ultimately it has to be how you are in
the room and make it's it's exactly like
you said the enlightenment i think that
excites the the scientist of course as a
charismatic person you have to
know what to pick
in terms of what excites you but that
that is also the fascinating thing to me
about hitler
is
all of these meetings even like with
chamberlain
inside rooms whether he was screaming
or whatever he was saying it seems like
he was very convincing there must have
been passion in his eyes there must have
been charisma that one-on-one in a quiet
conversation he was convincing
you